[music]
I'm Bruce Bower.
I write about behavioral sciences for Science News.
So I cover everything from psychology
to archaeology, anthropology...
[laughs]
If it's about human beings and how we think and behave
then that's pretty much what my beat is.
Psychologists are currently going through
a period of much angst and worry
over whether their science
can really be found to repeat their findings --
whether it's valid,
are they really onto something?
There's much discussion now
about how psychology should pursue this issue
and how can it be solved.
This is something that we are going to cover
quite a bit in Science News
because it applies not just psychology
but to many areas of science right now.
For scientists, reproducibility is very important
because what means is that
when they get one particular finding it's important to
know that people can find the same thing
in independent labs
with independent researchers
trying to see if the finding holds up.
So one aspect of the way psychologists
currently do business with significance testing
is to focus purely on the average scores of groups
and to compare the averages of one group to another
and if one average is considered
to be statistically significant --
or different enough from the other group --
then they consider that to be an effect.
But averages can hide just as much as they reveal.
And as we've recently reported in Science News,
it can be very instructive to look not at averages,
but at individual differences.
So when researchers recently looked at
individual differences between young children
learning what they call theory of mind,
or how to understand and make inferences
about what others are thinking and feeling,
The children showed very different rates of learning --
even older couple of years, from age three to five.
And I think right now,
given a lot of the controversy and the anxiety
over significance testing and lack of reproducibility,
there may be more of a focus on individual differences,
which would be a very healthy move for the field.
[music]